Good morning John. This week I flew in a tiny
plane to New York City where there were many
weird and fancy things. Here are some of them:
White asparagus, which was fed to me at definitely
the best restaurant I have ever been to. At
least the most expensive. White asparagus
is just asparagus that has never seen light,
and thus has a milder flavor and is not at
all green. This is weird for two reasons:
One: I feel like I have robbed asparagus of
reaching its full potential. And two: Because
who figured that out?
My hotel room had a mirror lens that I rather
enjoyed...
Ahhhhhhh. Errrweeeawagrrawahhherahhh.
Here's a tip, kids, when your umbrella breaks
in New York City, just throw it on the ground!
This urinal had ice in it. Why? I don't know.
I don't know! Pretty cool of the City of New
York to put this permanent installation of
TFiOS clouds in Central Park. I mean that
is just... That is just real nice. And finally
here are some tiny chairs that cost MCUH MORE
than normal sized chairs. And here is Time
Square, and what is that? That is just an
advertisement for the movie that they are
making out of my brother's book. The real
reason why I was in New York, and yes it was
great; I wish I could have seen more weird
stuff, but that is not why I was there. I
was there to see the premiere of The Fault
in Our Stars. The first time I had seen the
movie, and also to walk down the red carpet.
Which was cool, and lots of people took pictures
of me, but maybe just 'cause I asked them
to. Everybody take lots of pictures, I want
lots of flashes. Yeah, yeah. I say that because
none of them published any of the pictures
of me and my wife, which is too bad. But,
good news, my mom took a bunch too. And also
did you see how pretty my wife is? So pretty.
Katherine: "I feel like there is a bead of
sweat rolling down my back headed for my butt
crack."
And then I watched a movie, and I can't show
that to you 'cause copyright. Also, that would
be a really long YouTube video. And I am having
a hard time figuring out what to say about
it because it was super surreal. So here's--
we're just going to intellectualize... hyper-intellectualize
'cause that is what I am good at. This is
the book that I finished while I was in New
York. The Shades of Milk and Honey is like
Jane Austen with magic in it. One of the big
questions that books asks is are beautiful
things more or less beautiful if you understand
all of the hidden systems that go into the
creation of the beautiful thing? And as I
walked around New York, I kept seeing examples
of hidden systems on display. Like the escalator
at the Uniqlo had a window in the side so
that you can see how the escalator worked
on the inside. In the Museum of Modern Art
Design store, which one can assume has pretty
good tastes, was just full of examples of
this.
I think for a long time the trend has been
to hide the complexity. To hide the systems
in favor of this illusion of effortless perfection.
Hide the technology inside of the beautiful
box, right? So turn all entertainment into
a magic show. Construct the celebrity as this
perfect embodiment of cool. But since we started
here on Vlogbrothers, we have kind of been
doing the opposite. That is the whole point!
This is my real office. I am not wearing makeup.
We make T-shirts with a local printer; here
is how the process works. John's book is being
turned into a movie. Here's some videos of
the cast and crew on set. Here's how John
fells about it, and here's how I feel about
it. Right now how I am feeling is, I'll be
honest, overwhelmed. I'm afraid that we are
missing opportunities. I'm afraid that every
time that I talk to the New Yorker or The
Wall Street Journal that I am just going to
come off without the ability to say things
that make any sense. And I'm worried about
all of the external attention. But there is
one thing that I am not worried about. I am
not worried that people won't like the movie
or that the movie is bad because it's not.
It's great, and people are going to love it.
And yeah, I cried. I cried a bunch of times,
but not 'cause it subtracted from me. But,
because it added to me. It opened up the mysteries
of life, and love, and hurt for examination
and for understanding. And I think that that's
something that the world needs more of. John,
I'm proud of you! Everybody, go see the movie
whenever it comes out in your country on the
day that it comes out in your country! John,
I'll see you on Tuesday.
An advertisement for the book-i-dabawheebakalawhooaha.
Ahhhhhhhhhhh.